well a new mixed-use community is
looking to bring something pretty unique
to the valley we're talking about
uncommons we'll soon open at durango in
the 215 in the southwest valley near
ikea and not too far from the soon to be
built durango casino and resort joe
moeller got a look at the construction
shows us what to expect
[Music]
durango casino and resort broke ground
just behind us here last week but before
that opens a unique shopping experience
will be coming here to the southwest
valley the southwest valley is booming
right this is uncommon the biggest thing
that we're bringing to that valley is a
sense of community and belonging emily
zinser is the uncommons director of
community she says other areas of the
valley like henderson and summerlin have
their community centers and shopping
uncommons wants to be that for the
southwest valley we have a local coffee
shop that we can't wait to announce we
also have earth cafe that's going to be
the first location off of the strip
several office buildings tower over the
shopping area several businesses have
already signed leases you have a full
building that draft kings took over
zinser says between durango casino and
resort and on commons the southwest has
plenty to be excited about i was raised
with town square i was raised with
sunset station
and all of that made a large impact on
how you could gather with friends
and this is another another stake in the
ground for las vegas and something that
we're really aiming to have and it's
community first people can expect art
music areas and events like farmer's
markets here we're made in las vegas
alicia alexander is opening the cocktail
inspired candle shop speakeasy candle
company she'll be one of the first to
open you are allowed to
come and create your own luxury candle
we'll be here to guide you through those
steps she says her store will not only
be a unique experience but so will on
comments my life is on durango my kids
go to school on durango so we're excited
that a footprint like this is coming to
our community as construction continues
on the uncommons here they say they'll
have businesses opening throughout 2022
but they expect the first business to
open here by summer reporting in the
southwest valley joe muller live local
now